[Musique]
soit
de mes pensées
isabelle boulay c'est le dernier cinq
minutes avec avant noël donc on va genre
de noël on ne voit ça avec plaisir un
nouvel album de noël franc succès huit
mille exemplaires vendus en une semaine
bravo merci merci vos réactions comment
vous expliquer ce que ce soit toujours
aussi populaire les disques de noël
mon dieu moi je suis un vrai bon public
des albums de noël j'en ai j'en écoute
beaucoup j'en ai acheté beaucoup et ça
m'a pris énormément de temps avant de
mettre commettre et d'en faire un
justement parce que j'apprécie vraiment
ce mais je voulais à mon tour faire un
disque qui allait faire le même effet
sur les autres que tous les disques que
j'aime et que j'écoute dans cette
période là lorsqu'on dit chansons de
noël on pense souvent la nostalgie donc
retour en arrière gaspésie simplicité
oui lorsque vous étiez tout petit
quelques chansons écoutées vous à m'ont
dit on écoutait beaucoup de chansons en
français chez mes parents donc mon beau
sapin ce minuit chrétien les chants peu
plus religieux sainte nuit moi j'en ai
chanté beaucoup parce que j'étais dans
une chorale d'enfants mais chez ma grand
mère et ma tante adrian c'était un peu
plus la musique quand tu es donc il y
avait des gens nekkache qui chantait
noël elvis presley
c'est pour ça que j'ai repris du
christmas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sauf que
t
[Musique]
les chansons de noël ont vraiment sont
faites pour chanter en famille ensemble
parce que les études tendent à démontrer
que ça fait du bien de chanter ah non
mais à l'esprit oui en tant que
chanteuse le sentez vous sur ce beau
livre là oui oui moi si je suis trop
longtemps sans chanter ça me réussit pas
beaucoup c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
un vrai un vrai exutoire le chanter pour
moi c'est comme prendre une sortie ce
coup
je
donc quand ça fait trop longtemps que
mon instrument à pavie brill ça ça se
ressent sur sur mes humeurs mon
caractère puis je peux vraiment
comprendre que chanter même si on chante
pas juste c'est une chose qui est
tellement tellement belle tellement
essentiel ça ça nous redonne de la vie
ça nous fait vibrer ça nous fait chanter
ça nous fait nous sentir vivant ses
remplaçants
[Applaudissements]
tous les bus
de charme
france la première fois qu'on s'est
rencontré il ya une vingtaine d'années
lors d'un un beau lancement du disque je
pense c'était au lion d'or à montréal
donc commencer peut-être transfert soit
un goût vous avez dit récemment en
entrevue tout le monde en parle que vous
auriez peut-être dû au cours de votre
longue carrière peut-être mieux
surveiller les choses
oui de quelle façon tu parles de sa mort
son bain parce que en fait c'est ça
serait très très long à mais disons que
moi je suis plutôt cigale que fourmi
donc et les contres que je fais dans ma
tête si si j'ai un contrat moral avec
quelqu'un je vais je vais le respecter
donc pour moi la parole donnée vaut
beaucoup j'ai une façon de faire aussi
qui est très à l'ancienne je fais mon
métier
j'aimerais ça continue de faire le
métier comme on le faisait il ya 20 30
pas parce que mes modèles à moi c'est
c'est des gens qui ont fait j'ai j'ai
rencontré plein de gens heureusement bon
c'est une chance mais c'est côtoyer
henri salvador et gianni johnny hallyday
aznavour mireille mathieu nana mouskouri
voir travailler ces gens là moi j'avais
la chance quand j'étais aussi plus jeune
a dit mme moi j'ai eu des longues
conversations avec claude léveillée
c'est un bénéfice pour moi donc
mais c'est vrai que je dirais que je
paye encore aujourd'hui des des choses
que j'ai que j'ai pas pris le temps de
surveiller dans mon passé
isabelle boulay dans quelques jours ce
sera noël alors joyeux noël merci je
vous souhaite la bonne année qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour 2020 pour 2020
j'aimerais beaucoup entreprendre les
démarches pour faire un disque avec
t-bone burnett donc
j'espère je vais écrire une lettre comme
j'ai fait quand j'ai voulu chanter avec
dolly parton je vais écrire une lettre à
la main puis on va voir ce que ça va
donner
j'aimerais vraiment tendre merci merci
merci
même si tout autour chômage que si
furieux les ans
quant à eux de retrouver tous les noël
en temps
[Musique]
et penser
isabelle boulay c'est le dernier cinq
minutes avec avant noël donc on va
garder noël on voit ça avec plaisir un
nouvel album de noël franc succès huit
mille exemplaires vendus en une semaine
bravo merci merci vos réactions comment
vous expliquer ce que ce soit toujours
aussi populaire les disques de noël
mon dieu moi je suis un vrai bon public
des albums de noël
j'en ai j'en écoute beaucoup j'en ai
acheté beaucoup et ça m'a pris
énormément de temps avant de me
connaître et d'en faire un justement
parce que j'apprécie vraiment ce mais je
voulais à mon tour faire un disque qui
allait faire le même effet sur les
autres que tous les disques que j'aime
et que j'écoute dans cette période là
lorsqu'on dit chansons de noël on pense
souvent la nostalgie donc retour en
arrière gaspésie sainte-félicité oui
lorsque vous étiez tout petit
quelle chanson écoutée vous à m'ont dit
on écoutait beaucoup de chansons en
français chez mes parents donc mon beau
sapin ce minuit chrétien les chants peu
plus religieux sainte nuit moi j'en ai
chanté beaucoup parce que j'étais dans
une chorale d'enfants mais chez ma grand
mère et ma tante adrian c'était un peu
plus la musique comme tu es donc il y
avait des gens nekkache qui chantait
noël elvis presley
c'est pour ça que j'ai repris 12
précieuses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il sort
m
[Musique]
les chansons de noël ont vraiment sont
faites pour chanter en famille ensemble
parce que les études tendent à démontrer
que ça fait du bien chantez maintenant
mais à l'esprit oui en tant que
chanteuse le sentez vous sur ce beau
livre là oui oui moi si je suis trop
longtemps sans chanter ça me réussit pas
beaucoup c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
un vrai un vrai exutoire le chanter pour
moi c'est comme prendre une sortie de
secours
je
donc quand ça fait trop longtemps que
mon instrument à pavie brill ça se
ressent sur sur-mesure mon caractère
puis je peux vraiment comprendre que
chanter même si on chante pas juste
c'est une chose qui est tellement
tellement belle tellement essentiel
c'est ça nous redonne de la vie ça nous
fait vibrer ça nous fait chanter ça nous
fait nous sentir vivant c'est iron plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux chambres
vance la première fois qu'on s'est
rencontré sur une vingtaine d'années
lors d'un autre beau lancement dis ce
que je pense et et au lion d'or à
montréal donc commencer peut-être enfin
son goût vous avez dit récemment en
entrevue tout le monde en tant que vous
auriez peut-être dû au cours de votre
longue carrière peut-être mieux
surveiller les choses
ah oui de quelle façon je suis pas vu de
sa mort son bain parce que en fait c'est
ça serait très très long à mais disons
que moi je suis plutôt cigale que fourmi
donc et les contres que je fais dans ma
tête si si j'ai un contrat moral avec
quelqu'un je vais je vais le respecter
donc pour moi la parole donnée vaut
beaucoup j'ai une façon de faire aussi
quitterait à l'ancienne je fais mon
métier j'aimerais ça continue de faire
le métier comme on le faisait il ya 20
30 pas parce que mes modèles à moi c'est
des gens qui en fait j'ai j'ai rencontré
plein de gens heureusement bon c'est une
chance mais c'est côtoyer henri salvador
reggiani john à l'idée asnav ou mireille
mathieu
nana mouskouri voir travailler ces gens
là moi j'avais la chance quand j'étais
aussi plus jeune a dit mme moi j'ai eu
des longues conversations avec claude
léveillée c'est un bénéfice pour moi
donc
mais c'est vrai que je dirais que je
paye encore aujourd'hui des des choses
que je n'ai pas pris le temps de
surveiller dans mon passé
isabelle boulay dans quelques jours ce
sera noël alors joyeux noël merci je
vous souhaite la bonne année qu'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite pour 2020 pour 2020
j'aimerais beaucoup entreprendre les
démarches pour faire un disque avec
t-bone burnett donc
j'espère je vais écrire une lettre comme
j'ai fait quand j'ai voulu chanter avec
dolly parton je vais écrire une lettre à
la main puis on va voir ce que ça va
donner
j'aimerais vraiment tendre merci merci
merci
même si tout autour change que si
furieux les ans qu'on ne te retrouver
tous les noël
en temps
[Musique]